who would you say is the well it doesn't
have to be one person but who would you
say is the coolest person you've met
like as as a fan or as a as as an
admirer of that person like who would
you say who if someone if I asked you
who is the coolest person you've met I
mean in the anime industry it probably
be here Yuko for me because I've been
I've been a big fan of his work for like
you're not going to say Kevin
[Laughter]
pink Kevin Kevin knows he's a boy man
Kevin shut the [__] up like I'm not your
favorite composer no because like it's
it's great right because I remember the
first time we met Kevin and we got like
pissed together and he starts talking
about how like his like how he composed
for like made in abyss and his process
for everything like that and he starts
talking about this really like technical
composition like talk and I'm like man
this is really [__] interesting um
this is like like a lot of people would
love to hear this this is like a really
interesting conversation but we were
like pretty hammered at that point right
and so I remember making a mental note
being like man I got to I got to hear
this again sober because this is like
some really interesting stuff in your
head you were like wow this is really
interesting but what came out was shut
up pink shut up Kevin so like the day
afterwards um the day afterwards at
crunchy World expert I'm like Matt like
so what were you saying about composing
like that that scene with mey and like
all that stuff like can can you just
repeat what you say CU that like super
interesting Kevin just goes N I have no
idea what the [__] I was
saying I was [__] pissed mate oh my
God I [__] love him I love him so
much he's he was so oh man cuz I
remember the first time I met him IRL
was when we all
wento and you know the moment I saw him
at that you know at the pub I was like
oh [__] that's Kevin penin but then the
moment he opened his mouth he was just
he went from Kevin penin to oh look an
Aussie like the moment I knew that we it
was going to be like fine we were all
going to get on was like I sat down he's
like right I'm get get round
then Fant okay and if you know what a
round is in the UK and Australia we have
this thing where I think it's a way to
like trap you into having at least like
seven drinks basically it's a system
where and this Probably sounds like hell
to like like social some doesn't drink
yeah it's basically like if there's like
four or five of you someone buys the
round which means that they buy all the
drinks for everyone and then you kind of
rotate who does it but obviously you
can't just then have one you have to go
through the whole cycle because you
don't want to be that guy who doesn't
pay for their round every know you're
the stingy one you don't want to be in
debt with anyone so you're you're
getting at least as many rounds as there
are people on the table right that's
that's just like how that's just how the
drinking culture works it's such a
horrible social trap because when you
think about it like in terms of the
amount of money you spend it's literally
net zero right if you make it through
the entire round but for some reason
you're just you you're locked into this
until the round is completely over
horrible I feel like whenever I try to
get Americans to do this like no that
sounds stupid why would we do that I'm
like no no just do it just do it it's a
social thing justy it's it's like
logically it's like yeah why would get
everyone drunk yeah but it's it's just
it's just a way to get everyone drunk
and everyone Social cuz like you're all
in this together
right the moment you sit down you are in
the
cult you cannot leave yeah God so like
Kevin we're just [__] I okay I'm I'm
I'm this is just a
10minute this this this is a 10-minute
Kevin R like if you hang out with Kevin
he has this thing called oong high or
oong die and oong high is just like the
worst [__] drink with that gives you
the worst hangovers cuz it's like
whiskey and oong right
yeah or is it Shu andong it's sh Show
some [__] disgusting [__] um and like
he he orders this every time and I did
not know that you could order like ulong
High by The Jug in karaoke places but he
found a way to order it by The Jug in
karaoke places you want you want a
oolong high right I'll try it I guess
two jugs come in I'm like
Kevin this isn't what kind of sample
size is
this what the [__] God damn that is that
is the most Australian [__] like
phrase or oong
die my God yeah and then there's this
one other time when I went to [__]
Yaki Niki with Kevin and it was like it
was like all you can eat as well right
so so Kevin took all eat as he takes the
menu and he orders two of everything of
the menu cuz he was just that hungry so
much disgusting stuff as well that yeah
and just like the food kept turning up
and it was like and he didn't tell
everyone that he was ordering this much
food so we would finish this and we were
like it was like that se that scene in
seven where the guy overfeeds like the
first like sloth guy like to like kill
him that's what it felt like see the
reference
going like cuz you were just eating food
and you were like your your stomach was
already like expanded Beyond like f it
like felt like my stomach was [__]
Jupiter or something you know that's how
expanded it was and then as soon as we
finish another round of [__] Yaki
Nuku comes I look at Connor we're like
why why did we sign ourselves up for
this yeah we made him like tell the the
kitchen like like stop like stop like
stop the order we take it back like [__]
go
back oh my a yeah well we can't wait to
have Kevin on the show if you couldn't
already tell